films can do many many things and
sometimes they can just leave you broken
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's October we got Halloween coming
up I figure this is the best time to
pull the trigger on something I've been
thinking about for a little while which
is a list of ten movies and/or movie
moments that freak me out
or at least did at some point in the
past this is kind of an odd mix so like
say for instance when I did my movies
that movie scenes that made me cry that
it that was a list you know dominated by
things that make me cry every time some
of the things that we're gonna talk
about were things that freaked me out as
a kid and I more or less got over but
like even watching now still like
reminds me that they used to freak me
out some of these are individual scenes
some of these are whole movies this kind
of runs the gamut but here we go with 10
movies or movie moments that just kind
of yeah oh and one other thing before I
get started
none of these are jump scares these are
all moments that actually stick with me
past the moment of the temporary move so
keep that in mind so starting with
number 10 and we'll start with one that
is admittedly it's kind of silly but it
really did unsettle me that's Pizza the
Hutt yeah from Spaceballs and yes this
was the same movie that had a very Alma
that had basically the identical scene
from the alien birth scene from alien
just without blood and that disturbed me
way less than this creature I know what
it is I think it's something about the
way he pulsates and you know they
studied like the guys with him so
picking bits off of them and eating them
it's it's just gross and I mean it
that's what it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be gross but in this
particular case it was gross in a way
that really kind of left me like
Oh as a kid and what I would rewatch
this phone when I was younger I would
tend to skip over the pits of the hot
scene cuz yeah kind of freaked me out
it doesn't really anymore but I watch it
now and I do get like sort of it my got
a little yeah okay
will we out from that number nine the
descent now the descent is one of my
favorite horror movies and it is worth
pointing out that I am NOT
claustrophobic however watching this
movie I kinda regret it seeing it in the
theater
more specifically seeing in a theater
with slightly cramped seats where I
couldn't stretch out my legs as far as I
would like because I find myself a
myself as this movie Juan really wishing
that I could just like confirm that I'm
not confined because that this movie is
shot and constructed so masterfully to
make you feel enclosed and make you
empathize with the characters and the
fact that they are trapped and I don't
want to spoil stuff that goes on later
in the movie for in case anyone hasn't
seen it but if you are claustrophobic I
would actually say don't watch it at all
and even if you aren't I would be
shocked if it doesn't at least get you
to understand why people get that way
yeah I tell you that was no better
feeling that the end of this movie than
being able to walk outside and be in the
open air I really needed it after this
one so let's move along number eight the
ring basically the whole movie um I I do
okay with it now but first time I
watched it it really it made me really
tense like it like in a way that wasn't
especially fun at the time I think it's
just the way the film builds and the
sense of dread in the atmosphere and
like the the little things that are off
like the fly in the video G pauses it
and plucks apply out of the screen and
you know the the the way the horses
react and then you know ultimately
seeing
you know her crawl out of the the TV
screen at the end I I'm not gonna spoil
it I feel like everybody knows what goes
on in the ring at this point it's been
parodied so much it's one of those
things that like everybody just knows
but oh man that that movie made me real
that I can't there are not many movies
that made me as tense watching them as
this one did because generally movies if
they rack up tension for me it's like
for a scene it generally doesn't keep
building scene overseeing overseeing
over scene and it really did with me for
this one
yeah yeah that was definitely rough
especially the first time number seven
requiem for a dream now this one is one
that kind of freaked me out in a
different way from a lot of the others
because this one is just it is sadness
that feels oppressive and the way that a
good horror movie or scary movie can
have an atmosphere that feels oppressive
a sense of dread that feels oppressive
an ever-present threat that feels
oppressive this is just sadness to the
point of oppression and yeah if you
haven't seen this movie like if it
wasn't as steeped in adult content as it
is I would say just forget about
anti-drug you know education and in
schools just show kids this at about
fifth grade they will want to touch
anything for a while and I mean a big
part of why it works is that it's not
it's not reefer madness it rings true it
makes sense and the reason what makes it
so depressing is that it starts at the
beginning with drug addictions it starts
when things are good it starts when you
know these people are taking these these
things you know for their various
reasons that that they do and it's
working for them it's giving them what
they want but then over time it doesn't
anymore and watching it spiral over time
but also understanding how we got here
because you saw
in the beginning it worked for them it
gave them that sense of fulfillment that
life wasn't giving them and then to just
watch it escalate and fall apart around
these characters over the course of the
film is it's just it's crushing is what
it is and there's no one specific scene
but it is just so oppressively
depressing that it left me shaken like
in a way that I would compare to
something like sometimes black mirror is
able to do it just know like I I I
needed I needed again I need to go
outside like breathe the fresh air and
you know see some birds something um
after I saw this movie number 6 dipping
back again into childhood the Dark
Crystal and this one is likely Pizza Hut
is it it is a specific scene and it is
the death of the Skeksis Emperor at the
beginning of the movie and so he's in
this bed and he is this emaciated
gasping and he's kind of like this to
his breathing and he just looks so sick
he just looks like absolute death and
you know this sort of desperate Lassiter
he has before he dies and then crumbles
and literally falls apart that really Oh
like watching it still I'm like yeah
that that's hard that's that's that's a
that's a tough thing to for me to see
even now but especially as a kid like
that that was like a the predominant
image that's stuck in my head of the
Dark Crystal for a while because that
just emaciated sickly
thing just falling to pieces oh yeah
next up number five from annihilation
and this I would consider to be a bit of
a spoiler for this movie but yeah I need
to talk about this thing it's not like
ending spoiler but the moment if you
didn't already know about it yeah I'm
gonna dig into it now and that's the
bear scene now there's actually a lot
about this movie that really left me
kind of going oh but the thing was most
of it like intrigued me like I was a
little unsettled but I was also sort of
drawn in the bear scene just left me in
a state of horror so in case you haven't
seen the movie the ho boy it's hard to
explain what goes on in here in this
area basically things are living things
are melding together in bizarre ways and
it is resulting in animal or plant just
things like I have abominations for lack
of a better term that are just there but
very much behaving as if they've always
been there but are very clearly new and
very very very wrong and what goes on
with the bear is there there was earlier
in the film it was one of the group got
yeah well got killed and then one of
them starts to crack under the pressure
and she hears the dead companion outside
this house that they've taken shelter in
you know screaming going help you know
yo yeah and I'm not just saying I like
screaming oh god and she runs out to try
and you know save it and what it ends up
being is it is this bear with almost no
flesh on its skull and when it opens its
mouth it doesn't roar
it screams in this woman's voice helped
me and something about the the
desperation and the sincerity of the
terror in the voice of this dead woman
that and the fact that this bear isn't
necessarily even doing it trying to lure
anything out it's just when it opens its
mouth that's the sound that comes out of
it it's it's so wrong it is so wrong on
so many levels and it just that scene
just lingers and it is I mean it's a
tense scene if even if that had not been
a messed up bear and it just been a bear
if that's still a really tense scene but
the fact that it goes down the way that
does it's oh man like that that's the
stuff of nightmares
number four Blade Runner the original
again this one counts as a bit of a
spoiler because it's a late scene in the
film but this is kind of an iconic film
if you're gonna watch it you probably
would have by now
so the death of Eldon Tyrell at the
hands of Roy batty what it is it is a
head crush with the thumbs in the eyes
and you're probably thinking oh liking
Game of Thrones from that fight between
the mountain and Delgada Oberyn Martell
and sort of and while the while the Game
of Thrones take on that kind of death
was more brutal and was certainly more
graphic there's something about how long
it takes or at least how long it feels
like it takes in Blade Runner because
you hear initially you just hear these
breaths of Tyrell breathing as he kind
of
starts to feel the pressure of Roy
crushing and you slowly you know see you
know him struggling in Roy's hands shaky
and then you hear the crack and that
crack and it and it's this muted crack
because it's his skull cracking but it's
happening you know under his skin so
it's this muffled drawn-out crack and
Tyrell starts to scream and it it's
really really rough I mean I loved that
movie that's one of my favorite movies
but that I I tend to get up and uh you
know use the bathroom get a drink of
water I find a reason to not be in the
room when that scene happens it's Oh God
okay so next up number three this one is
gonna include spoilers and there's
really no way around that because it's a
movie that I don't think a lot of people
saw and I think even fewer people
remember but I'm gonna talk about it
anyway it's a movie called four lions
this was a movie I came out I forget
what year it came out I'd been in around
2010 or so and it was sort of it cause a
mild controversy at the time because it
was it was a comedy about terrorists it
was a comedy about would-be suicide
bombers and that's what it is it's a
British comedy and it's about this group
of young men who want to they want to be
suicide bombers they they believe in the
cause and they they want to die for that
purpose but they're also really bad at
it and so there's a lot of you know sort
of the dark British humor about the fact
that these guys aren't very good
but at the same time you know it's not
like it makes fun of terrorism as a
thing it just makes fun of these
specific guys who are just really bad at
it but the the main character in it
I think it's called Omar but in any case
what what left me deeply disturbed about
this movie and I and I don't consider
this a failing even though it's a comedy
I think it's my it's my belief that it
was intended to be disturbing on this
level he has a wife and a daughter I'm
sorry not a daughter a son he has a wife
and a child and he loves them and they
love him and they know what he's gonna
do and they're supportive and that is
incredibly unsettling that someone with
all this to live for and he's got like
he's got a decent house he's got a
decent home life he's got all these
things you know the reasons that so many
people hang on and push there's so much
crap in their lives and he still wants
to do this and in the end of the movie
he does he does blow himself up and the
scenes of him interacting with his son
Italian bedtime stories and having this
wonderful relationship with his wife
they disturbed me far more than the
actual bombings did or ever could it
just shook me at a fundamental level and
I don't know how many other people have
that experience watching this movie I
don't even know how many other people
have seen this movie but that I think
I think at the time I saw it I don't
think my daughter was born yet but I do
think that her mother was pregnant with
her and we knew that so I sort of I knew
that was gonna be in my future and so I
was starting to get into that parental
headspace so this
I haven't rewatched this movie since I
saw it for the first time I'm not sure I
have it in me to ever do it number two
under the skin now this movie as a whole
is pretty unsettling but it is one
specific scene that I'm gonna focus on
because as much actually quite a bit
like annihilation much of the other
scenes were unsettling in a way that was
intriguing but there is one scene that
oh my god okay I'm just gonna have to
describe this scene
and again this might be considered a
spoiler it's about halfway in or maybe
not even that far so you know take what
you will from it so first I need to kind
of try to explain this movie which is
his own weird thing so Scarlett
Johansson is playing what appears to be
an attractive young woman and she goes
about an area talking men who don't know
her into coming back to her place where
this happens like it's it's it's really
abstract and it's really bizarre and
it's supposed to be but it's also as a
in between you know the the vibe and the
way it's shot in the music you there's a
very sinister vibe to it you know that
whatever is going on is not good so but
there's a scene on a beach and she's
chatting up this guy you know near the
beach which is something we've seen her
do we've seen her go through this cycle
before so we know what she's up to
and the guy sort of stops Eichner and
goes because there is
there is this family a father a mother
and a baby on the beach and the mother
who was swimming is getting pulled out
by the tide and the father has gone in
to the water to try and save her and
he's not having much better luck and
this guy that Scott Johansen was was
trying to chat up he he dives into the
water and he he drags the husband back
to land
um but the husband doesn't stay he goes
back out to try and get his wife and the
the the swimmer of the guy who you know
who tried to rescue him he's he's laying
panting exhausted on the beach and
scholars your hands and walks up to him
and picks up a rock and bashes his head
in and says I'm trying to remember
exactly how how part of this plays out
cuz I have not really watched this but
she she takes his body and this is all
happening afternoon ish and she leaves
but then she goes back for his stuff
that's still on the beach and what left
me deeply yeah I mean the this scene
already was pretty unsettling pretty
disturbing but what left me deeply
deeply shaken was she goes back to the
beach at night it's dark and the baby's
still there
it's sitting where it was left it looks
confused it it just needs help from
somebody from penny buddy she doesn't
even notice it walks past it picks up
the stuff and walks and leaves like I
honestly think it would have been less
disturbing if she had stopped to kill
the baby I would have found that less
disturbing than this complete failure to
acknowledge this helpless child yeah
that that scene in the way it escalated
as a whole is it's honestly probably the
single most disturbing portion of film
that I have ever seen like I the only
reason I didn't turn the movie off was
because I didn't have the strength to
push buttons on the remote now that
might seem like well this should be at
number one and it's not necessarily that
my number one is more disturbing on the
whole then that one scene is but the
reason my number one is at number one is
that under the skin as unsettling and
effective as it is it kind of the the
spell kind of broke for me in the tail
end long story short I basically wrapped
my head around what was going on a
little too well like what once I
actually felt like I understood properly
what was happening
um and had kind of had a sense of where
was gonna go when it's last stretch and
and like for even a moment felt like I
understood Scarlett Johansson's
character kind of the spell was kind of
broken so it didn't quite stick the
linee it didn't totally fall apart but
it had been so unsettling up to that
point then I kind of just I kind of
coached it through the last 20 minutes
or so so the reason that my number one
is my number one is because it is such
the complete package of utterly
unsettling disturbing speaks to
certainly to me my core fears that is
invasion of the body snatchers 1978
version so this is the second film
version of this particular story and it
first of all it's got a phenomenal cast
it's got Donald Sutherland in it it's
gay it's got a young Jeff Goldblum it's
got Leonard Nimoy it's got Veronica
Cartwright it's it's really a terrific
cast and if you if you've never seen any
version of this story it is exactly what
it sounds like there are aliens who come
down and they replace people with a
looks exactly like them and has all
their knowledge duplicate but things are
just a little off and this movie has so
perfectly encapsulates that creeping
sense of dread that there's something
wrong with the world that you that not
only can you not put your finger on but
nobody else sees it speaks to so many
fears if it speaks to fears of isolation
it speaks to fears of self-doubt of
wandering if you are crazy it speaks to
the fear of never being able to trust
anyone it it speaks just
much and the worst part of it is they
get you while you sleep while you're
sleeping that's when you get replaced
and this movie I don't know how old I
was when I first saw it maybe 13 14 and
I so I've been watching this movie for
over 20 years and still to this day
whenever I watch this movie I have a bad
night's sleep I've screwed up dreams
every single time without fail and I
don't want to go into any more specific
detail about this movie because if you
have not see that I highly recommend it
like some of the movies that I've talked
about here even if you like kind of
being unsettled and freaked out a bit I
wouldn't necessarily recommend at least
as a blanket statement a lot of them
like under the skin I wouldn't not like
even anihilation which is a movie I love
that's a hard movie for me to recommend
I kind of need to know the specific
person and know what they like to be
able to recommend you know those kinds
of movies I just recommend this one it
is a good movie it is a really good
movie it is a really unsettling movie
and it is the escalation of how bad
things get and the sense that this
cannot possibly go well and I don't want
to talk about it any more than that
because I think if you haven't seen it
you should just go ahead and watch it
but yeah the the idea that you can't
trust the people around you you can't
sleep you can't trust your own instinct
about who your friends are all of that
just creeps in and builds steadily
throughout the movie because things are
off ever so slightly basically since
frame 1 of this movie and it just it's
like this infection of wrongness just
spreads
oh man that's an effective film and
still to this day I cannot watch it
without having a bad night's sleep I
screwed up dreams and that is why I have
to give it my number-one spot when I
talk about movies or movie scenes that
just freak me out
so that's my list folks what are some
movies or movie moments or scenes or
what have you that really pushed you to
your limits or maybe you even like had
to turn off a movie whatever it is think
about it and drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's
also a whole bunch of stuff you could do
because there's buttons and there's
links including one to my patreon if you
feel like supporting me that way if you
don't don't worry about it because just
remember folks you're the council I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]